ich möchte eigentlich alle die weniger
als 100000 euro verdienen entlasten
deswegen sagen wir in unserem programm
wir wollen die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge deckeln
damit dann auch tatsächlich mehr netto
vom brutto dann auch entsprechend übrig
bleibt
[Musik]
finden sie das deutsche steuersystem
ungerecht finden sie finden sie denn
dass die reichen zu wenig steuern zahlen
oder dass sie zu viel steuern zahlen
also zu wenig auf jeden fall also und
ich merke dass an kunden von mehr die
die sich einfach nicht mehr leisten
können zu mir zu kommen ich bin wirklich
eine günstige kosmetikerin und ja die
die buckeln die arbeiten die arbeit
sogar teilweise schwarz auch wenn das
wahrscheinlich richtig ist dass jetzt zu
sagen aber ich kann dir verstehen wenn
die gehören zu hause sitzen und hunger
haben ja da muss irgend wo die kohle
rein also hat dieser corona geschichte
hieß es immer soforthilfe soforthilfe
ein freund von mir der hat jetzt im juni
es gelder bekommt von oktober und
november
das kann nicht sein dann muss ich das
wort sofort wo seit heute morgen zur
gerechtigkeit und schwarzarbeit klar ist
nämlich richtig haben sie da irgendwas
machen genau schildern sie uns ihre
erfahrungen auch über die jahre haben
sie das gefühl dass die schere man hört
ja immer von schwere die auseinander
klafft zwischen arm und reich können sie
das bestellt ja entweder hast du was du
du hast nichts und die mittelschicht die
dümpelt eher so ein bisschen rum so ein
paar über geblieben sind da noch die
wahrscheinlich nicht wissen ob sie noch
wohin noch eine ob sie noch weit
darunter frei
aber so richtig ist jedoch nicht mehr da
also da muss man doch mal die kirche im
dorf lassen also sie fordern höhere
steuern für die reichen geben wir mal
rüber auf die andere seite der
donaueschinger der schere kann man ja
seine räume sagen arm und reich ebert
ist auch zu uns gekommen herzlich
willkommen haben sie auch im film
man kann sagen selfmademan sie haben
sich alles selbst erarbeitet was wir da
gerade zum teil auch gesehen haben sie
haben gerade in anführungsstrichen den
vorwurf auch gehört sie zahlen nicht
genug steuern sie tun nicht genug für
den sozialstaat fühlen sie sich da
angesprochen
also ich habe gerade das gefühl wenn ich
hier so mitfahre in der sendung und bin
selbst teilnehmer dass ich eigentlich
gerne auf beiden seiten sitzen würde
weil ich irgendwie jedem blickwinkel
verstehen kann ich habe das gefühl dass
sie natürlich pole jetzt hier und ich
sehe mich eher die beiden power mädels
bitte geht in die politik bitte die sind
so stark und so gut und ich denke im
einspieler habe ich gesagt mit dem
eigenen portmonee denken wenn ich
bedenke wo ich herkomme aus einer pleite
groß geworden ich war kellner und von
ganz unten angefangen und jeder dollar
den ich verdiene jeder euro ist so hart
verdient um überhaupt in die gewinnzone
zu kommen
vermögen aufzubauen und was jetzt auch
wieder alles mit corona in die firma
geflossen ist und da muss ich sagen habe
ich tatsächlich auch das gefühl wenn ich
jetzt die firma deutschland sage ich
immer also die angela merkel hat ihre
mitarbeiter wie denn jens und der schaft
cholera und gibt gas und arbeiteten
schuft oder macht und tut und das beste
pferd im stall sozusagen immer wieder
mit achter hat er da genug dann könnte
ich doch danach oben halt deckeln und da
mal oben deckeln
das ist glaube ich demotivierenden stück
weit für die besten pferde im stall aber
ich finde auch auf der anderen seite
sitzen die besten pferde im stall einem
an einer anderen stelle und ich habe
auch mit der bei der existenzen
alleinerziehende mütter in meiner firma
und denen muss es auch gut gehen weil
dann geht es mir auch gut und dass diese
schere von der wir sprechen
die muss aus meiner sicht immer wieder
ein stück natürlich dass es band nicht
zerreißt er auch zusammengeführt werden
und möglicherweise ich nehme das mal mit
zu herrn scholz gehört ärgern zu
denjenigen die sie aber noch mal mehr
zur kasse bitten möchten ein ster guten
pferde im stall und er hat ja gesagt
dass auf der anderen seite auch gute
pferde im stall sind weisen nämlich die
idee haben ledige die 250.000 und paare
die zusammen über 500.000 verdienen
für die soll der spitzensteuersatz bei
der einkommensteuer von 42 auf 45
steigen ist das fair
ja ich glaube das muss man kann ja die
welt nicht sich malen wie man das
irgendwie am liebsten hätte alle zahlen
weniger und wir haben auch noch die
fähigkeit all die aufgaben zu
finanzieren die wir haben und wir haben
ja gerade eine große krise gestemmt ich
habe die summe noch mal genannt und
wiederholen sie nochmals in 400
milliarden euro kredite die der
bundeshaushalt aufgenommen hat ab 226
zahlen wir knapp 20 milliarden davon
jedes jahr zurück das ist viel geld und
in der situation kann es jedenfalls
nicht darum gehen dass die leute die
sehr viel geld verdienen mit
entlastungen rechnen können und
umgekehrt wenn wir ehrlich sind und
sagen wir wollen das erreichen dass
jetzt die beiden hier schon angesprochen
haben und viele bürgerinnen und bürger
sich wünschen nämlich dass es eine
entlastung im unteren bereich gibt dann
können wir das nur durch zusätzliche
schulden finanzieren das bild der
brinkhaus nicht das will ich auch nicht
oder aber dadurch dass wir sie wollen
keine zusätzlichen schulden
wir haben eine haushaltsplanung auf den
weg gebracht die jeder nachlesen kann
da steht drin dass wir den rahmen den
wir im rahmen des grundgesetzes haben ab
2023 aber die schwarze null ist was sie
das sagt der parteichef raten sie mal
welche apa schneidiger in das steht
sogar im haushaltplan sie sind gerade
auf einer falschen fährte de nicht
vorgelegt habe das kabinett beschlossen
hat mit dem die regierung zu lassen was
einfach wir haben gesagt wir werden der
zusätzliche kredite aufnehmen in den
nächsten jahren aber in der
größenordnung von um die zehn milliarden
um das mal zu sagen ein bisschen mehr
bisschen weniger das hat nichts zu tun
mit den riesigen mengen die wir jetzt
haben wir schöpfer unsere möglichkeiten
nach dem grundgesetz aus aber wir werden
im rahmen des grundgesetzes handeln und
deshalb nochmal die aussage aus meiner
sicht ist wenn man das macht
gerechtigkeit für diejenigen die wenig
verdienen die normalverdienende sogar
ganz ordentlich verdienen indem man ihn
eine steuerliche entlastung verschafft
nur möglich
wenn auf der anderen seite ein bisschen
mehr gezahlt wird es gibt magnolia
unglaublich große summen aber es geht
darum dass man diese wahrheit ausspricht
stellen wir die gleiche frage herrn
brinkhaus spitzensteuersatz um gespräche
über die einkommenssteuer von 42 auf 45
prozent
wir sagen es nochmal 150 250.000
verheiratete 500.000 ist das fair so die
zahlen schon 45 prozent also die über
260 270.000 jetzt liegen zuzüglich
solidaritätszuschlag der noch nicht
abgeschafft ist und im übrigen
vielleicht noch einen hüpfer merkel zum
thema schulden bleiben wir wirklich
gelernt schwarze null
sie haben von der schuldenbremse
gesprochen wir haben es wirklich
verstanden ja erst das macht uns aber
kurz war ja aber eine sache müssen sie
mir eben gestand sie ganz kurz er
verschweigt 1 ermöglichen schulden auf
europäischer ebene machen also ist
einfach hier zu sagen also in
deutschland halte ich mich an die regeln
er ist von der gemeinschaft und der
schulden in europa jetzt zum
spitzensteuer genau das ist ja die frage
also ich glaube mal wenn ich beide sehe
dann ist es so dass ist der
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen gibt
und es ist so dass wir eine balance
finden müssen wir verteilen sehr viel um
in deutschland das heißt also wir sind
die umverteilung meister in europa und
sorgen dafür dass reichere leute weniger
haben dass leute die schlechter
verdienen mehr haben das ist ein system
was also entsprechend auch läuft und was
auch funktioniert und was auch gut ist
ich möchte auf eine sache aber auch
hinweise wir reden immer von steuern
ich glaube frau web sei sie zahlen
wahrscheinlich mehr
sozialversicherungsbeiträge als die
steuern zahlen und deswegen dürfen wir
bei der ganzen sache 1 nicht aus den
augen lassen wenn die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge durch die
decke gehen ist das für menschen die
weniger verdienen wesentlich mehr
belastet als wenn die steuern durch die
decke gehen
und deswegen sagen wir in unserem
programm wir wollen die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge deckeln
damit dann auch tatsächlich mehr netto
vom brutto dann auch entsprechend übrig
bleibt und sie weniger lohn nebenkosten
haben und dementsprechend auch mehr
leute einstellen spricht der gelernte
steuerberater und wirtschaftsprüfer ist
alles komplett steuerbare steuerberater
wurde was gehen nicht so ganz verstehen
ist herr brinkhaus sie wollen keine
neuen schulden machen und eigentlich
wollen sie auch nicht die steuern
erhöhen
sie brauchen aber doch geld um zu
investieren es gibt
viele probleme in deutschland woher soll
das geld hinkommen das geld kann nur
kommen wenn es erwirtschaftet wird und
erwirtschaftet wird es nicht traurige
mitteilung für sie durch hohe
unternehmensgewinne sondern
erwirtschaftet wird es durch viele gut
und fair bezahlter arbeitsplätze und
deswegen muss unser ziel sein dass wir
möglichst viele gut und fair bezahlte
arbeitsplätze kriegen weil das sind die
lohnsteuer gekommen das sind die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge gekommen und
das sind dann auch die mittel die dazu
dienen dass man sich ihre produkte
entsprechend leisten kann und ich glaube
das ist in unser aller interesse
ich komme ja aus der cdu da gab es ja
den urvater der wirtschaftspolitik der
cdu ludwig erhard und der hat ganz
bewusst nicht gesagt wohlstand für
wenige sondern er hat gesagt wohlstand
für alle und das muss unser ziel sein
und dafür müssen wir die unternehmen
entfesseln weil wir glaube ich überhaupt
kein gegensatz haben zwischen ihnen und
ihn natürlich gibt es unternehmen die
lücken ausnutzen und das ist nicht gut
dafür gibt es betriebsräte da sind sie
drin
ich war da auch mal drin wahrscheinlich
aus dem ähnlichen grund wie sie weil ich
gesagt habe ich möchte ungerechtigkeiten
dann entsprechend beseitigen das ist
auch gut so aber wir haben natürlich
ganz ganz viele unternehmen die super
toll mit ihren mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter umgehen wo die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter ganz
lange dabei sind die auch gut zahlen und
deswegen gefällt mir eins nicht dass der
gegensatz aufgemacht wird auf der einen
seite zwischen unternehmen denen es gut
geht und auf der anderen seite
arbeitsplätze die gut bezahlten dagegen
sei es besteht ja zwischen ihnen beiden
parteien die spd möchte umverteilen wenn
man so will und an der spitze
die steuersätze erhöhen sie setzen vor
allem auf das wirtschaftswachstum und
die frage ist doch ob das funktioniert
ja das funktioniert wenn wir eins nicht
machen wenn wir jetzt neue bürokratische
vorschriften machen ich will ein
beispiel das aber nennen sie doch mal
nötige wachstums seien also müssen sie
sich ja mal durchgerechnet haben na ja
also ich meine wir brauchen schon also
erst mal wieder die vor corona zahlen da
müssen wir ganz schnell hinkommen bei
sonst haben wir nicht genügend
steuereinnahmen und dann muss die sache
auch entsprechend weiter gehen um die
investitionen dann auch entsprechend zu
finanzieren aber das ist besser als wenn
ich jetzt einfach sagen ich nehme jetzt
irgend jemandem was weg das mache ich
einmal das nicht zwei mal und da nehme
ich auch also die entsprechende substanz
weg und vielleicht noch ein satz zu den
spitzen steuersätzen
es ist ja nicht so dass das nur für
fußball profis gilt sondern ein großteil
der spitzensteuersätze wird von
selbstständigen handwerkern unternehmen
als personengesellschaften gezahlt die
machen aber nicht eins dass sie das geld
dafür ausgeben dass sie sich irgendwo
eine finca auf mallorca kaufen sondern
die stecken dann wieder ins unternehmen
rein und deswegen sagen wir höhere
spitzensteuersätze fehlt geld für
wachstum wenn geld für wachstum fehlt
können keine neuen arbeitsplätze
entstehen wenn ich schon beim rechnen
bin gebe ich ihnen auch noch eine
rechenaufgabe herr finanzminister wir
waren ja bei der höheren einkommensteuer
sie werden das durchgerechnet haben mit
wie viel milliarden rechnen sie dann
wenn das kommt ich rechne überhaupt
nicht mit mehreinnahmen
das will ich ausdrücklich dazu sagen
wenn wir das steuersystem gerechter
austarieren nimmt der staat wenn man es
so macht wie ich mir das vorstelle am
ende nicht mehr eins zahlen nur einige
wenige alle die da sitzen wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe und ein paar
ganz wenige zahlen etwas mehr und zwar
auch so dass sie das gute grafiken
können sie es denn beziffern bei einem
durchschnittslohn von 25.000 euro
jahresgehalt zum beispiel wie was an
entlastung ist als 60 euro 70-80 es sind
geringe beträge die dann anfallen alles
zusammen sind ist natürlich dann
milliarden
und deshalb kann aber dafür für
einzelpersonen werden einzelpersonen ist
es dann eine entlastung die auch jeweils
stattfinden muss und deshalb sage ich
ausdrücklich wir müssen eine entlastung
im unteren und mittleren bereich
zustande bringen ich finde dass man auch
ganz klar sagen soll
das geht schon auch um noch ganz
ordentliche einkommen dabei und wenn wir
über etwas mehr zahlen reden reden wir
über diejenigen die sehr hoch verdient
warum kriegt man frau besser sitzt da
und schüttelt so ein bisschen wir können
jetzt ja uns eine tabelle hier gemeinsam
mich auch interessieren
aber nein das ist aber um es ganz klar
zu sagen wenn wir eine entlastung machen
dann geht das stück für stück weiter und
mein ziel ist dass wir eine genau das
tun was hier gewünscht worden ist
nämlich eine rechts verschiebung machen
ist der spitzensteuersatz der heute
erhoben wird erst später erhoben wird
damit eine entlastung für viele zustande
kommt
möchte eigentlich alle die weniger als
100.000 euro verdienen entlasten und
dann kommen auch sie zu einer entlastung
und klar ist dass das beste was man dann
noch braucht natürlich gute löhne und
wachstum sind das wollte ich dazu sagen
wir brauchen das wachstum aber um das zu
finanzieren was wir uns für die nächsten
jahre vorgenommen haben
wir brauchen wachstum damit wir zum
beispiel die investitionen im
bundeshaushalt finanzieren können viel
viel geld 50 milliarden haben wir uns ja
vorgenommen jedes jahr und wir brauchen
wachstum damit wir diese großen schulden
die wir jetzt zur bekämpfung der korona
krise aufgenommen haben
auch finanzieren können alles andere das
würde ich gerne dazu sagen es aus meiner
sicht boudou wer glaubt man kann allen
sagen wir lassen euch und dann kommt das
geld schon irgendwo rein macht etwas das
nicht aufgehen wird deshalb muss man so
klar sein
jede entlastung im unteren im mittleren
und ganz guten einkommensbereich ist
gleichzeitig etwas das ein wenig von
anderen mitgetragen ganz gut sehen sie
es mir nur noch das ist da gerade noch
mal nachgehakt habe wegen der konkreten
cyber man will immer wissen entlastung
was heißt es dass 50 euro im jahr seines
100 euro im jahr war wir werden es dann
vielleicht später erfragen wir sozusagen
den den voodoo priester der
unions-bundestagsfraktion also so hat
herr scholz ja die unteren einkommen
angesprochen
wir haben über den spitzensteuersatz
gesprochen lassen wir uns über die
unteren einkommen sprechen da steht im
cdu oder im cdu csu wahlprogramm und wir
blenden es kurz ein
wir werden kleine und mittlere einkommen
bei der einkommensteuer entlasten
wir versuchen ja dass hier heute abend
wirklich konkret zu machen also heißt
das wenn frau dreikorn cdu welt die cdu
weiter an der regierung ist dass frau
dreikorn am ende dann mehr netto vom
brutto auf dem konto hat also wir haben
ja auch einsatz davor geschaltet um
malaysia voodoo ecke wieder rauszukommen
und ihr die seriöse finanzierung
reinzukommen die wolfgang schäuble als
sein vorgänger immer gehabt hat die für
uns auch sehr sehr wichtig ist wir sagen
wir wollen uns durch wirtschaftliches
wachstum spielräume erarbeiten und diese
spielräume dafür nutzen um auch
steuersenkungen für kleine und mittlere
einkommen um zusammen
also sie hat von uns eine sache erst war
schon mal konkret zu erwarten dass wir
dafür sorgen wollen dass die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
das sind nämlich die steuern des kleinen
mannes und der geringverdiener dass die
entsprechend nicht steigen dass die
konstant bleiben das wird herausfordernd
genug werden so und das ist ein
versprechen das machen wir auf alle
fälle die andere sache ist dass wir
sagen wenn wir uns die spielräume
erarbeiten dann geht's halt eben nicht
nur darum das unternehmen entlastet
werden sondern da müssen wir fair sein
dann müssen wir die balance haben sie
haben ja gerade gesagt sie sitzen auf
beiden seiten und haben für beide seiten
verständnis
und dann müssen wir beide dann also auch
gleich entsprechenden lassen es wäre
jetzt aber unseriös wenn ich jetzt sage
es sind jetzt 750 euro im jahr das sind
500 euro im jahr weil erst müssen was
mal erwirtschaften damit war die
entlassung auch gleich direkt an frau
dreikorn die reaktion von ihnen
versuchen es hier so konkret wie möglich
zu machen hat sie da was überzeugt also
nicht so wirklich weil ich höre immer
nur wir wollen wir wollen wir wollen der
machen sie es doch endlich mal
[Musik]